c'est l'invité du 19/20 ce soir thierry
lacroix le meilleur buteur de la coupe
du monde de rugby 95 s'apprête à
intégrer le club orléanais
il est intégré en qualité de directeur
de rugby bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
avant de poursuivre je vous propose
qu'on en revienne en images sur votre
carrière benoît brière montage laurent
vori
[Musique]
c'était une autre époque un rugby encore
amateur thierry lacroix exercé le métier
de kinésithérapeute avec son frère
jumeau pascal demi d'ouverture au
premier centre le joueur né dans le gers
se révèle à dax à la fin des années 80
et donne déjà à ses conseils pour bien
but et ça commence par la position du
volant légèrement qui n'est pas vers
l'avant puisque je frenche énormément la
balade insolite de mourir l'angle au sol
ensuite donc ma course d'élan croient
pas ou cinq panneaux cnpa 3 pas sur le
côté
justement pour être un peu décalée
puisque je foch et puis bon vision je
visionne les poteaux après je regarde
que l'impact du ballon et je frappe du
turn et thierry lacroix et rapidement
appelé en équipe de france pour côtés de
jean françois tordo olivier roumat ou
encore laurent cabannes il connaît sa
première sélection en 89 face aux
wallabies et remporté son seul tournoi
des cinq nations en 1993 en marquant un
essai au parc des princes face à
l'ecosse
le chemin qu'il a retrouvé un groupe
avec l'équipe de france on touche est
entreprenante et c'est ça qui est
positif en 1994 et termine meilleur
buteur du championnat il est logiquement
sélectionné un an après pour la coupe du
monde en afrique du sud
dominateurs en poule les français
battent les irlandais en quarts de
finale mais s'incline face à l'afrique
du sud en demi
dans des conditions dantesques abdelatif
benazzi avait sans doute ce jour-là
aplatit dans l'en but mais l'essai
refusé dans le vestiaire c'est
l'abattement
malgré cela thierry lacroix termine
meilleur marqueur de la compétition avec
112 points repérée et tenter par
l'aventuré
il reste en afrique du sud pour jouer
avec les sharks du natal il remportera
deux kurys cup avec son ami olivier
roumat en 95 et 96 de retour en europe
il rejoint l'angleterre au sein du club
des arts le queens la deuxième année
termine quatrième du championnat puis
reste à londres et signe chez les
saracens
il rentre ensuite en france à perpignan
et restera le tout premier joueur à
avoir accepté un micro sur lui hand
rencontres professionnelles les gars
calmez vous auquel ils n'ont ils nous
opposent l'agressivité de leurs folies
faut qu'on se calme nous faut qu'on
construise en 2003 il termine à castres
sur un nouveau titre
victorieux du bouclier européen est à 37
ans il raccroche les crampons après 20
ans de carrière au plus haut niveau
serial buteur boulimique d'expériences
et boute en train
thierry lacroix devient ensuite
consultant sur france télévisions avant
de s'en aller vers de nouveaux horizons
alors tiré la croix qu'est ce que ça
vous fait de revoir ces images qui ont
ponctué votre carrière ne rajeunit pas
déjà non c'est sympa je crois que le
rugby a évolué mais il garde quand même
son adn qui est avant tout le copinage
le sla et l'esprit de sacrifice
la convivialité aussi parce qu'il ya
troisième mi-temps qui doivent toujours
existé c'est ça qui nous fait nous
fédérer auprès d'eux justement les
spectateurs ou des partenaires en tout
cas le rugby a évolué mais il a il n'a
pas oublié que c'est quand même un sport
de combat et de contacts il est gardé
son bon esprit et je le disais tout à
l'heure vous êtes désormais directeur du
rugby du rc haut avec une telle carrière
comment est-ce que vous en êtes arrivé à
ce club de quatrième division
en fait c'est simple j'ai pris au dessus
du rhône et je me suis dit bon mais
voilà il ya une pénurie de club de bon
niveau en top 14 et pro d2 pour ceux qui
sont parus glissé première division et
deuxième division à partir de là il ya
une analyse qui a été fait sur des dom
et des données économiques aux sportives
puisque j'ai fait un master d'économie
du sport et là dessus mais quand vous
prenez aujourd'hui en club de rugby est
une entreprise même au niveau amateur on
évolue d'une association vers une sas
est donc belle tout le monde ne l'a fait
pourquoi pas le rc eau et leur coc
positionner comme un club ambitieux avec
des données économiques intéressantes
pour devenir un jour référent en tout
cas la loire et pourquoi pas un central
justement qu'est-ce que vous comptez
apporter à ce club
quel est votre objectif l'objectif déjà
c'est d'amener des compétences parce que
tout club associatif la problématique
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de bénévoles
avec de bonnes intentions mais il manque
quelques compétences il manque une
structuration qui vous fait avancer vers
le haut niveau donc cette équipe
effectivement on a commencé à structurer
on
c'est à faire venir aussi un groupe de
jeunes qui a intégré la cellule
économique sportive marketing et on va
un petit peu a donné autour de nous
toutes nos compétences pour que
justement cette région sorte un jour un
club de top 14 et pro d2 vous avez déjà
rencontré des joueurs j'imagine certains
vous ont déjà marqué iliad a quelques
heures mais on a une bonne pépinière il
ya de très bons jeunes joueurs
les u16 et u18 sont d'excellents joueurs
on a on a quelques bons joueurs
sélectionnés dans certains équipe de
france donc la formation est bonne
aujourd'hui aliance important c'est la
base pour de tout développement
maintenant il faut après b franchir ce
câble qui est la maturité c'est comme
l'équipe de france on sort souvent des
moins de 20 ans championne du monde mais
après ça gagne plus rien donc c'est on
le retrouve aussi dans les clubs au
niveau national est ce que votre
notoriété peut permettre d'attirer
l'attention sur orléans d'attirer
l'attention de sponsors par exemple ça
l'fait effectivement il faut s'en servir
je suis un homme sandwich
donc il faut s'en servir de temps en
temps effectivement l'intérêt et portait
effectivement sur orléans aujourd'hui
parce que j'y suis d'ailleurs beaucoup
de jeunes du rugby français on sait que
le rugby quand même commune une histoire
de sud-ouest sud-est le nord comme je
les dis au dessus durant ne s'est
compliqué et là le fait que certains
joueurs de notoriété viennent passer
l'eau du rhône mais ça ça donne de
l'intérêt à des sponsors des médias et
puis à des joueurs aussi de venir nous
rencontrer et apprendre notre contact
un dernier mot quelle est la prochaine
échéance sportive pour le rc off
mais c'est en match la marque embarras
il samedi et puis le premier match à
domicile le ici au rc au le vermont
octobre contre sarcelles
à ne pas louper on suivra attentivement
merci beaucoup thierry lacroix d'avoir
été l invité du 19/20 ce soir merci